chief exec
of network rail is uh with us how's it
looking
well it's devastating for passengers i
mean this is a this is a wasteland it's
like the darkest days of covert
passengers alienated from the railway
because we can't run a service for them
and uh
breaks my heart it's
really really apologize to passengers
who are facing that and we know there's
some real life
issues for people who can't travel today
it's just it's so wrong who's running
the trains that are running
uh
well the trains are being run by train
driver because they're not on strike but
we have um managers who are fully
qualified to be signalers and things and
who are running the signal boxes
uh but that's what we've only got a
limited number of them which is why
we've got reduced hours of operation and
why some routes are not open how much
have you offered um rmt uh um i'm not
going to negotiate with the rmt on you
know
others are saying three percent neither
of those figures are correct we've been
clear
than that it is a lot more than that
because what we've said is
there's real inefficiency in britain's
railways we can be more productive we
can save the taxpayer money and we can
do a better pay rise for colleagues in
the role as well and that's what we want
to do we want to reform working
practices that are holding the railway
back
and that means we can unlock then a
better pay rise for the workers they
want seven percent
like i said i'm not going to get into
specific numbers so however however many
times you ask me but are you anywhere
near that though
look we can there's real it depends how
much reform we get that's the point i
think there's really huge reforms that
we can do to work and practice we've got
some crazy outmoded practices
that drive inefficiency that make the
railway less safe actually make it
harder for people to work here
but um you know
we've we've had a real resistance for
making those reforms we want to make
those happen we want to talk to the rmt
and get the railway running again mr
sharps the transport secretary said he
would it would make matters worse if he
was in the room for negotiations do you
agree with him oh i do look i've worked
in the private sector and you'd never
have the shareholder in the room it's up
to management to talk to the trade union
yes the government sets a framework but
they've given me enough room to
negotiate it's the fact that the rmt
doesn't want to facilitate the reform
that's the issue here
how would you describe the mood of the
rmt when they're negotiating with you at
the moment
i would say generally good but just
every now and again it's as if
you know something belligerent takes
over them i mean we've had hugely
constructive conversations we think
we're getting there
on sunday evening eight o'clock we
thought we were literally within a
hair's breath of a deal by half past
eight they were walking away same thing
again yesterday it feels as if
uh you know we get them almost to the
line
and then they fall back when are you
going to start talking again
well hopefully tomorrow i think today
everybody is busy concentrating on
running a railway doing the very best
job for the few passengers who are
traveling
but like i want to talk to them we will
talk to them day and night 24 7 to try
to get the next strikes called off do
you think the strikes as as we speak now
are likely to go ahead on thursday and
saturday i think they're likely and i
think people should plan on that basis
but i will do everything i can to try
and turn that round but i can't i can't
be confident about that at this stage
what would you say to the rmt union if
they're listening right now
talk we've got real reforms which can
give a generous pay award
to my colleagues in network rail
that can actually be good news for
taxpayers for passengers and those
colleagues i don't think those
colleagues want to lose money i think
few of them can afford it we all know
what inflation is doing we know what the
cost of living is in britain at the
moment they don't want to be losing pay
we need to be talking
to get this fixed the government says
that if these strikes continue to go
ahead they're going to change the law so
that agency workers can do the jobs that
rmt members are doing at the moment with
that is that something you'd support
well it doesn't have a huge impact on us
uh because when you become a s
to be a signal or to be trained as a
contingent signal it's a huge amount of
preparation obviously because we don't
compromise our safety standards when
iota so it's not really practical but i
think in other parts of the industry and
other parts of the economy the use of
agency workers i know would make a big
difference certainly in my previous
experience in aviation it would help i
know other parts of the economy and i
think it's inevitable uh when we see
such intransigence over fundamental
reforms how frustrated are you
i think you can get the sense i'm
massively frustrated because this is a
wasteland it should be teaming with
passengers going about their daily lives
and as a system we're letting them down
and we can't carry on like that thursday
and saturday um if there is no
resolution will you be able to run a
similar level of service it's a sim yeah
it's effectively it's the same as today
uh for those uh future strike dates
tomorrow sadly disrupted because the
people who should be coming or not night
term to set the railway up for tomorrow
morning
will uh have been instructed by the mt
not to do that so tomorrow morning will
be really damaged we hope by late
morning a normal service running to the
end of the day but disruption as well on
wednesday friday and sunday and that's
why this is so so damaging okay good to
talk to you thank you so much for taking
the time